200 entreprises et près de 2000 offres
d'emploi voici ce qui vous attend le 29
mars prochain au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en piste pour
l'emploi proposera plusieurs espaces
dédiés au recrutement et à la formation
un événement qui se veut novateur c'est
un moment très pédagogique pour pour un
vendeur d'emplois mais en même temps
très activateur puisque il est
directement en rapport avec près de 200
entreprises qui sont à sa disposition
toute une journée pendant 12 heures avec
un taux de chômage de 7,2 pour cent au
dernier trimestre 2010 est le
département des yvelines affiche une
situation plutôt favorable par rapport
au reste de la france
néanmoins la part des demandeurs
d'emploi inscrits depuis plus de deux
ans continue à augmenter
première observateurs de cette tendance
pôle emploi qui sera présent lors de
l'événement
nous avons d'ailleurs des conseillers
pôle emploi qui animeront tout au long
de la journée nous aurons également des
conseillers pôle emploi qui vont
accompagner leurs demandeurs d'emploi
notamment parmi les porteurs de
l'accompagnement intensive jeunes et qui
viendront effectivement accompagner les
publics tout au long de cette journée
vraiment enrichissante
le numérique tiendra également une place
importante lors de ce rendez-vous
information animation mais aussi job
dating attendre les futurs participants
qui s'inscrivent ils regardent et la
tirer c'est que les
et chefs d'entreprise vont regarder les
cv donc il ya déjà après une
présélection qui sera faite par rapport
à un certain nombre de critères ça c'est
important
et puis
il ya également les gens qui veulent
venir sans son inscription
objectif pour saint quentin en yvelines
que chacun puisse trouver le 29 mars un
emploi durable